a tout de suite prendre la direction de
l'ukraine pour ea a retrouvé notre
envoyé spécial catherine norris trent
bonjour catherine je lisais carson est
donc tombé après des combats acharnés
bonjour florent oui effectivement de le
maire de la ville d'harare san a
confirmé l'arrivée des troupes aux
rousses russe excusez moi et et dit être
en dialogue avec ses forces russes dans
le bâtiment de la mairie même en ce
moment ils appellent aux habitants de la
ville de rester calmes cette ville de
300 mille habitants qui donne sur la mer
noire donc une position clé
stratégiquement parlant elle ya un canal
qui se situe au nord de la ville qui
donnait jusqu'à 2014 de l'eau fraîche à
la crimée 7 canal qui a été coupée par
les ukrainiens et donc qui serait une
point vital un point vital excusez moi
pour les russes pour reprend ça pour
aller monter la crimée avec de l'eau
fraîche on peut aussi imaginer que deux
personnes les forces russes pourraient
avancer à l'ouest vers le port d'odessa
et aussi vers l'est ils ont déjà pris la
vie nnent le porte ville portuaire
voisin de milito paul donc il ya une
avancée significative dans le sud
l'ukraine pour l'instant en ville
aujourd'hui la situation reste calme
après des combats acharnés le maire de
la ville avait parlé de plusieurs morts
dans les rues et il appelait un couloir
humanitaire pour pouvoir évacuer ces
morts et des blessés il demande au
révérend de ray ressentent de rester
chez eux de ne pas sortir il ya un
couvre-feu strict la nuit et seules les
personnes amenant des vivres de la
nourriture des médicaments seraient
autorisés à entrer en ville donc tout
est très tendue mais les forces russes
sont bien et bel présent dans la vie des
personnes une première prise d'une
grande ville dans le sud l'ukraine pour
l'armée russe est un peu plus à l'est
catherine la bataille pour marioupol
elle s'intensifie ces dernières heures
sur place plus d'électricité plus d'eau
plus chauffage il faut dire que la
capture de marioupol par les forces
russes pourraient constituer une étape
importante dans ce conflit notamment
pour cette fameuse continuité
territoriale catherine
effectivement donc la situation à la
très très difficile pour les habitants
de mario paul qui vivent sous un juge du
siège excusez moi depuis plusieurs jours
donc les coupures d'électricité de
communication téléphonique beaucoup de
bombardements d'artillerie sur les zones
civiles de la ville on a pu parler avec
des gens ces derniers jours qu'ils
étaient dans la ville qui parlait de
civils morts qui plusieurs amené à aux
hôpitaux qui galérait les hôpitaux à
gérer tous ces blessés qui arrivent et
donc une situation plus que difficile
et effectivement cette ville portuaire
est aussi très très important sur le
plan stratégique elle est à l'extrême
sud laisse sud-ouest excusez-moi de
l'ukraine et sa prise ferai en sorte qu'
il y aura un couloir terrestre tout au
sud l'ukraine menant des territoires
occupés par des soi-disant séparatiste
pro-russe dans l'est des craintes dans
le dos de basses jusqu'à la crimée donc
il serait très important sur le plan
stratégique un poids vladimir poutine
merci infiniment